hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous update you've
seen us talking about the rain and the
importance of storing the water on your
land
and in the end i showed you this big
lake hidden here between
these bushes and i never really saw the
lake properly myself because it's fully
covered with
trees bushes it's just been neglected
there for a while apparently it's also
natural spring
so in today's update we're going to
clean it up and making sure we can
access it and see what's actually
underneath all this
[Music]
stuff
[Music]
okay to give you a bit of an overview
our base camp is right
here and here's the swamp we cleaned in
update 9
and here is the lake which is currently
also a big swamp
and as you can see it's very close to
the base camp but
super hidden i mean it's somewhere
between these bushes
with a road very close by but from the
road you don't see
anything strange all right so before we
start i want to show you guys one big
upgrade this week
it's a chainsaw and it's an electric
battery powered one
yeah so now we can chop a lot of trees
thank you guys on patreon for supporting
i actually wanted to make a video about
this because it's kind of new technology
and see how it behaves
how is it compared to a gas powered one
does it last long does it have enough
power
so i was recording this editing this and
then i realized
i don't want to make a review video for
something that i used for a week
so i'm not going to upload the video
make sure to remind me in half year or a
year from now
to upload the video and actually at a
conclusion like half a year later
to get a proper review anyway for now
time to start chopping some trees
yeah so today we're gonna clean this
swamp
right here taking out all the trees and
bushes
and we have matia here to help yeah it's
happening
where the chainsaw so what's the plan
so i think we're gonna clear this side
out first
and chop all the trees bring them aside
and then we're gonna
uh obviously close the other end and
i guess a couple of days should be done
already
yes
[Applause]
uh
okay so end of day one and we've done
all of this path
and we only been working a couple of
hours
but there's still quite some left see
here we've done maybe 10 meters
but there is way more ahead of us
[Music]
so we've now been chopping a lot of
trees and now we need to
drag them out uh outside of this little
forest
[Applause]
so over here we made a bit of space so
this is already all the trees we took
out piled up
electrical
been clearing all the way until the top
now we have a few big trees to chop down
in the afternoon
and we've got to clear out all the
broken trees that have fallen onto the
swamp as a result of the fires so
i guess dave is going to jump in have a
little bath i don't think so and
what you're doing yeah my phone just
dropped in there
no there's scissors just dropping it
[ __ ] end of the day little bath
it's quite nice though doesn't stink
[ __ ] what
[ __ ] you now
i think i'm gonna have to go in
so next up we're going to chop all the
trees here so we can drag them out over
the pot we just created
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
first swim of the year to be nice and
lovely
[Applause]
it's nice
fun time yeah
so here we are after lunch
food coma all right all the trees have
been taken out
we left a little bridge in the back
because we thought it might be fun to
jump from there
and we also had a little dip in the
water which is nice and cold
and quite deep actually and next i think
we're gonna finish
cleaning up all that stuff there
[Applause]
still didn't go
[Applause]
all right so the lake is now cleaned up
and we can actually see it
and we can also access it super easy and
turns out it was pretty big
a lot of water but also a lot of trees i
mean really this is the pile of dead
trees we dragged out
and hear the young trees i mean looking
from above it's a lot
especially compared to the size of the
lake
big piles of wood so yeah now our
satellite image looks different
we now have a lake all right so that was
this update the lake is now
uh opened up and we can access this take
a swim
uh next up we're gonna look into can we
actually get drinking water out of this
so we need to do some water testing
um but also making sure it has pressure
so using pumps or gravity
still a lot to figure out if you want to
see where this is going make sure to
subscribe so you can follow it
and um make sure to visit
support.projectcamp if you want to help
out
so you can help us get a new scissor
that matia lost
or help us fund a scuba suit with a big
led light so we can go on the bottom of
this lake for hours to just search for
that scissor
but it's quite expensive getting this
whole scuba stuff so
yeah make sure to visit
support.projectcom.com
see you in the next update and thanks
for watching